Is it true that cancer cells will use glutathione for their own benefit?
Well, yes, they will.
So cancer cells will use glutinate cells.
So cancer cell member is just your own cell that is rapidly replicating that it's going to need a lot of glutathione.
So yes, it will use glutathione for its own benefit.
And there, you know, I've taken the position at different times throughout my career that maybe a cancer patient shouldn't be on a lot of glutathione.
But I've kind of reversed that decision based on new information that has come out that is more beneficial to decrease the oxidizing agents in your healthy cells.
I know that cancer cells uptake glutathione very well, just like they don't uptake any nutrition very well.
That's why most cancer cells go and start reproducing and implemented state through what is known as the warberg effect because the waste that is around the growing cancer doesn't allow
for oxygen to be transported very well to it.
So it ends up being a hypoxic warberg effect.
So no, I don't think that that's an issue.